now when I heard this idea I said hmm
aren't there free dance videos on
YouTube yes there are and then you
educated me let's educate the audience
as to the difference between the dance
videos I did with Mahalo back in the day
sure which got millions of views and
made us lo thousands of dollars sure you
are making close to a million dollars a
year I think off of subscriptions show
us how it works yeah so we are steezy we
create online dance classes with some of
the world's best instructors mostly
based out of LA and focused on hip-hop
right now but our goal is to teach any
dance style that you can think of so our
users are constantly requesting things
like ballet tap jazz salsa even
shuffling and twerking jazz jazz yeah
you want to be a you want to be teaching
I would okay so you're starting with
hip-hop sure and to my point how is it
different than going on YouTube or
whatever tick-tock and learning a move
on there yeah so there's a couple of
different problems with YouTube
tutorials obviously there's just so many
out there they're very you know
low-quality you don't know who you're
learning from so we want to be the
trusted resource for dance okay and
we've also built a very unique video
player that breaks down the entire
learning process that makes it really
easy and fun so for example you know as
dancers I started as a hip-hop dancer
and so I really understand like how
classes work and so the video itself is
mirrored right away so it feels like
you're falling on a mirror you can you
know switch views so you can also you
know learn from any angle that you want
you just went from the front view to the
back view yeah so I guess when you're
recording these you're recording from
multiple views yes but it happens so
instantly and snappy that's pretty cool
tech yeah so we built our own custom
video player we when we were trying to
figure out you know what is the right
product to build we looked around didn't
see anything that we liked so we just
decided to build it ourselves you know
just like in a dance class everything is
broken down and to move so YouTube
tutorials are typically like three to
five minutes but we tell the instructors
to really walkthrough move by move just
like you were in an actual dance class
and you know in classes you always want
to ask questions repeat things
you so we break down each class into
these reviewable sections so you can
always click back and review as much as
you want and we also built this really
cool looping mode that you can repeat
each section like over and over as many
times as you want so you can really
practice and drill that's like one of
the main selling points of steam so if
I'm trying to figure out how that
flossing work yes the dance from
fortnight I can loop just one little
segment of the floss and figure it out
yep oh that's super helpful yep and how
do you make money we sell subscriptions
surprised uh we are twenty bucks a month
or about a hundred and twenty dollars a
year we're still trying to figure out
you know the right pricing model to
really scale the business yeah and I
think he came to the incubator had fifty
sixty thousand a month yeah we had fifty
thousand yeah and now you've been
building out a studio we invested I
think seven hundred fifty thousand
dollars yes no maybe more the syndicate
did seven syndicate did 750 across
seventy three investor so on average 10k
that's pretty pretty high so people felt
some conviction
tell everybody what was the process of
going through the syndicate like sure
what throw it yes so we joined launch
incubator we met a bunch of different
investors all throughout the program met
a bunch of really great syndicate
investors how many investors do you
think you met during the 12-week launch
accelerator program Wow
definitely more than before I joined I
think it was like 40 or so 50 yeah at
least back then we were doing five a
week uh-huh
so 12 weeks 60 uh-huh now we do seven a
week yeah and then we bring now five or
six of the syndicate members yep so then
you meet all these investors what
happens next
yeah so right when we joined the program
you already were very convinced we could
be the next calm calm so it's very easy
to to get all the investors together we
did you know syndicate we presented our
deal memo launched out to the email list
and then we did a webinar and then how
did the webinar go what kind of
questions did you get really good
questions basic questions yeah they were
they were good questions you know just
like the typical smart savvy investor
questions that we would get asked
we would just answer them all together
and then it's very easy process yeah and
how much is raised total total we raised
three million dollars
you guys actually co-led the round with
your friend Dave Samuel from freestyle
Dave Samuel from freestyle which is a
great firm here you met them through the
program yeah they put in half the amount
of money we put in half so I think we
maybe did what do we do from our front
250 500 500 500 750 from this indicator
that's our biggest investment to date
from our fund yes we're congratulations
on that we just we know you're gonna
make it happen sure so now you go from
being a bootstrap stat or startup mmm to
having over two million dollars in the
bank sound right yeah three three yep
how mind blowing is that for you to wake
up one day from because you were living
essentially what month-to-month ordered
a quarter and how much runway did you
have typically in the beginning of 2018
we were actually only at two to three
months runway left and then we got to
cash flow positive and joined the
incubator got it so you were not
sleeping at night in the first half of
the year not at all you wake up a year
later after going through the lunch
acceleration you got three million
dollars in your bank account it's pretty
day yeah and I'm still not sleeping but
it's because you're so enthusiastic not
anxious sure yeah